in recent decades it has been normal to
consider the tenant of the white house
the president of the united states as
the most powerful person in the world
however dear viewer things they might be
changing
or maybe they've actually already
changed have you heard about the chinese
president well of course you have
because i'm sure you're a very avid
visual politic viewer now you see donald
trump himself in statements collected by
the washington post
described the chinese president xi
jinping as the most powerful leader
that china has had in the last century
which is as good as saying that xi
jinping is the most powerful chinese
leader of all time
so much so that more and more analysts
are wondering if he isn't
in fact the most powerful political
leader in the world
yes it's true now while china's economy
and its army are still on a second level
compared to the united states
trump seems to consistently be losing
his influence over the world and indeed
his own country and when you go over to
china you can see that the situation is
pretty much the opposite but wait wait
wait wait wait trump is losing his
influence in the u.s i mean how could
this possibly be the case he wants to be
everyone's friends
have only seen his rather sweet tweets
lately
why would kim jong-un insult me by
calling me old
when i would never call him short and
fat oh well i try so hard to be his
friend
and maybe someday that will happen yes
it's definitely no surprise that the
united states is losing his influence
over the world
in just a few months trump has gone from
nuclear war to
schoolyard fights all right anyway back
to the serious stuff the fact is that
although xi jinping isn't
the president of the world's leading
power he does control china's leadership
tightly a country which is one of the
most important economic engines
on the planet
and of course for beijing trump has been
something like the
lottery jackpot
protectionism nationalism and donald
trump's mistakes have allowed xi jinping
the president of the world's largest
dictatorship to present his candidacy
as a sort of global political leader in
january 2017 at the davos forum xi
jinping promised that china would become
nothing less than the champion of
globalization of free trade
and even the fight against climate
change thus beijing aspires but its
grasp on the terrain that has been
lost by washington
he only forgot to mention well you know
freedom and
all those other sorts of apparently
unimportant things
but now what happened in the last
chinese communist party congress
how much power does xi jinping have and
what does he want well we're going to
discuss
all of this but first let's take a look
at
china today
the new china
do you think that china is still a
country where people live in deplorable
conditions
breaking their backs for miserable wages
well i'm sorry but the reality is you're
actually pretty wrong if you think that
2018 will be the 40th anniversary of
china's reform and open policy
in this country it's changed a lot in
that time
china is no longer a low-income country
but indeed a middle-income country
in fact taking price differences into
account it could have purchasing power a
priority of about 16
000 which is bigger than both colombia
and brazil
also its economy has changed and
nowadays services
are the most important activity
for example in electronic commerce a
sector in which the country is beating
europe and even the united states
china represents no less than 40
of all global transactions the same can
be said of mobile payments which are so
popular in this country that its market
reached 5.5
trillion dollars in 2016 which is 50
times more than the united states
all of this could be described as not
bad i mean their growth has been so
large that just in the last six years
china's private consumption has grown by
2.5 trillion dollars an amount that
equals
india's entire gdp therefore when you
visit one of those
giant chinese cities it's not at all
uncommon to find a city full of
skyscrapers
billionaires and high-speed trains but
hold on just a second here because
china's poverty continues and in general
there is a
really large difference between the
country's cities and the country's rural
areas which remain
poor very poor
in fact they're so poor that 43 million
people almost the entire population of
spain by the way
still live in extreme poverty earning
less than one dollar a day
and not only that almost 40 percent of
chinese people still live at fairly low
economic levels
although the situation is much better
than a few decades ago
this is all true but as i said before
things are changing very quickly and we
can no longer think of china as we did
2010 or even just
five years ago
by the way talking about poverty here's
an interesting fact do you know
how the chinese government fights
against poverty well one of its main
strategies is actually creating new
businesses and cooperatives in the
poorest of communities to this end the
government has granted almost
400 billion dollars in small loans to
help launch several companies
and they not only focus on money but
also on culture
the evening news is filled with tales of
rejuvenated communities and villagers
turned entrepreneurs heaping praise on
mr c
and the government for providing loans
and new apartments javier c
hernandez china correspondent for the
new york times
yes yes i know xi jinping and
practically every country leader talk a
lot about
chinese style socialism the truth is
that this is just a reference to a kind
of capitalist model
locked up within a dictatorship china
isn't an ideological dictatorship nor a
socialist or communist one
it's just simply a dictatorship having
said that now let's talk a little bit
about xi jinping the person
leading this new china with almost total
power
xi jinping the leader
born in 1953 we could say that xi
jinping is a pretty interesting dude on
the one hand he's probably the chinese
leader who's had the most contact with
the west his daughter studied at harvard
his sister even lives in canada and he
has visited the united states
several times in fact in 2012 when he
visited the united
states as vice president of china he
made a somewhat peculiar stop he went to
iowa well at this point you're probably
wondering why did he go to iowa well the
fact is that in 1985 when xi jinping was
a young party county secretary in china
he traveled to iowa
to investigate agriculture-related
issues so in 2002 we went to see the
family that had stayed with at the time
and he brought them presents pretty cool
right in addition
president xi's yankee side it doesn't
end there he's also known to love
hollywood movies
but there is also another side to this
since he became china's highest
authority five years ago his government
has been characterized for having the
most
censorship and repression for a very
long time we only need to take a look
at the latest cyber security law which
seeks to control even more of the
internet in china by restricting
anonymity
indeed this is to such an extent that
all social network accounts have to be
backed by an
identified citizen further it's been
decades since china saw such a strong
leader
we could say that all this propaganda
has worked greatly but that's not really
surprising now is it
the fact is that in these five years xi
jinping has made several changes in
china
starting with the army reform and their
very active foreign policy we saw it
here at visualpolitik how xi jinping has
diverted national resources towards
foreign policy
a good example is this new silk road
macro project which aims to invest
hundreds of billions of dollars in
several countries but generally
their greatest commitment has definitely
been the fight against corruption
and this is seriously important
since xi jinping came to power over one
and a half million members of the
communist party have been sanctioned and
nearly
300 000 have been prosecuted including
43 members of the central committee
there's more within the framework of
this fight against corruption
13 000 army officers have been dismissed
and more than
50 generals have been imprisoned of
course as you might expect not everyone
sees this battle as clean and honest
it's a selective anti-corruption
campaign its nature is the selective
protection of corruption when you purge
some corrupt officials
you are protecting the others you
protect the corrupt system and you
protect
corrupt people who support you baotong
chinese activist
yes xi jinping has mostly relieved his
political rivals
coincidence of course it's very clear
that xi jinping has gained a lot of
power in these five years this was
certainly observed in the last chinese
communist party congress the most
important political event in the country
which is held every five years
the 19th congress
the 19th chinese communist party
congress held between october the 18th
and 24th 2017
was quite peculiar especially because it
may have been the most austere congress
that the chinese communist party has
celebrated in many
many years on this occasion some
amenities they were removed how about
some examples well among
other things there was no lavish buffet
there was no hairdressing there were no
facials and tailoring services i mean
all of these
used to be offered for free to
participants and it had almost become a
tradition but above all
this was the congress at which xi
jinping's adoration reached its highest
point
something that as you can imagine in
china means being put on an almost
mao-like level five years ago i said he
would be china's most powerful leader
since dam xiaoping i was wrong he is now
china's most powerful leader since mao
zedong
kevin rudd australia's former prime
minister see this congress led to the
decision that the so-called
xi jinping thought should be included in
the communist party constitution
this may seem a bit strange but it
actually means that xi jinping is no
longer just another leader he is in fact
the leader the leader whose words form
the party's own ideology
it means c is essentially unassailable
if you challenge c
you're challenging the party and you
would never want to be against the party
bill bishop publisher of the cynocism
newsletter so far only mao dong has
received such an honor in life
but that's not all currently a
president's mandate is limited to 10
years which means that this would be
xi jinping's last term but do wait a
minute here because no successor was
considered during the congress which
leads us to believe that xi jinping
may be at least aspiring to a third term
chinese universities scrambled to open
centers to study
president xi jinping thought but anyway
beyond the chinese border this congress
helped define
three major priorities for the chinese
government in upcoming years
first there's the economy which means
fighting poverty and opening up more to
the world
second there's the idea of launching
even stronger foreign policies and
third start worrying about the
environment and you know even though i
said there were three priorities there
is kind of a fourth and it's actually a
pretty clear one and that's
consolidate the communist party's power
and this is because we know two things
for sure on the one hand
xi jinping and the chinese communist
party will stay for a long time
and on the other hand china will reclaim
its role as a superpower so the reality
is we're going to have to get used to
taking beijing into account
now it's your turn we've got an
important question who do you think will
leave power first will it be xi jinping
or vladimir putin well you can leave
your answer in the comments below as
well as in
this survey and i really hope you
enjoyed this video and please do hit
that like button if you did and don't
forget to subscribe to our channel for
brand new videos every monday and every
thursday
also don't forget to check out our
friends at the reconsider media podcast
they provided the vocals in this episode
that were not mine and as always
thank you for watching
you